people here are terrified of the M23
armed group
when its Fighters attacked Army
positions near the town of sake
thousands of the people living there
fled
we saw the M23 appearing and a woman was
shot everybody is leaving the area and
running away
m23s widely understood to be a proxy of
neighboring Rwanda Democratic Republic
of Congo's Army says it's fighting
Rwandan soldiers Rwanda denies backing
the group
more than half a million people have
fled m23s advance in the last eight
months
the people here are walking to the
nearby provincial capital of Goma which
M23 has nearly surrounded
this wooden scooter is called a Chucky
it's a common means a transport in The
Villages and the hills around Gomer is
used for carrying agricultural produce
and sacks of minerals down into the town
but today it's being used by this boy to
carry whatever he could grab as he's
fleeing his home
[Music]
many people here say they don't
understand why the government hasn't
done more to support its forces and stop
m23s Advance
the rebels just appeared in our village
and we heard the gunfire and bombs so
people started leaving and running away
even the soldiers were also running away
with us
down the road in Goma some fleeing
soldiers were rounded up by military
police and sent back to the front line
vehicles on the road
heavier weapons arrived to help the
fight Rwanda says Congo is using foreign
mercenaries Congo says it's hired former
French soldiers as military instructors
the Army says it repelled the attack and
forced its enemy back up into the Hills
but still within the range of its
artillery
the residents of sake are left wondering
if it's safe to go home and if or when
M23 will attack again Malcolm Webb Al
Jazeera bulengo Democratic Republic of
Congo